isaiah garza is our drew gooder
ambassador and he is coming to us live
from the west coast
isaiah you have made kindness go viral
on social media and it is your mission
to share stories like this i must say
nobody does it quite like you and we're
about to surprise some very special drew
getters are you excited
i'm super super excited right now guys
okay so i would love for you to see this
backstory take a look
the first time i met teldrick he was in
third grade
he was um just moving from another
school into the school that i work at
i've never had that experience before
where you just meet someone and you kind
of know like there's something that's
different or special about them so i was
gonna go on a solo backpacking trip for
the summer and it was a couple days
before i was leaving and his mom called
and she was pretty upset and she said um
you know teldrick was airlifted down to
children's hospital
last night and he's not expected to make
it
i went down to the hospital he was in
the pq at children's hospital hooked up
to i mean hundreds of machines it was
insane i've never seen anything like it
in my life he woke up probably five days
where he was out of the coma he was
awake and he was starting to move he was
showing signs that he was understanding
it was a true miracle i did foster
teldrick for six years
and then finally in march of 2021 he was
legally adopted and finally told rick
albrecht
which he's been wanting a long time
everyone always says oh my gosh you
saved teldrick but
in reality he did he probably did save
me too
it was someone to give my life purpose
and guidance
um just to
kind of just put you in the right
direction you know
something was lacking like a bigger
picture a bigger meaning was lacking
from my life i think at that time it was
definitely tilde
so
just put me on the right path and gave
me purpose meaning and a sense of being
a parent it was awesome
[Applause]
along with the crew from the cbs 2 los
angeles and they have no idea that
they're about to be on this show
um and we have a massive surprise for
them isaiah i love you let's do this all
right let's do this
hi kim and
hello
hi how are you guys we're really good
how are you good good
my name is isaiah from the drewberrymore
show
how you guys doing good we're wonderful
isaiah all right let's come outside i
got some for you guys
[Laughter]
hello hi
smile you're on the drew barrymore show
guys
[Applause]
hi guys hi guys kim um you say hi say hi
hey you sue sorry you say that um you
knew that you always had a special
connection
um to teldrick when he was your student
and i was just curious if you could tell
us about that there was just this really
positive aura with teldrick um from the
day i met him
uh the smile on his face the light in
his eyes uh so full of joy and happiness
and
he just brought that
everyone around him he brought that to
everyone around him there's just
something about him and i'm wondering
what that moment was like when the
adoption was official when he became
your son and you became a family
honestly that was the best moment of my
life
um it was a whirlwind of emotions
relief
happiness joy
yeah yeah we find each other
absolutely amazing um kim
tell me how do you want this story to
inspire others well i hope that this
story inspires others that people will
believe in miracles teldrick truly is my
miracle i never in a million years
thought that
that he would be my son and we're here
doing all this now um
but miracles are out there they happen
and uh also i hope it inspires people to
adopt these children are everywhere
and uh if it's even in your mind at all
go go for it and do it because the bond
that you'll build with this child is
unconditional oh
tim another thing i heard you do to
expand your horizons is that you guys
love to travel together
we do love to travel together
but you had to stop in the pandemic
right you had to cut a trip off even
that you had planned
we sure did we were in december we were
gonna go to bali for three weeks and um
obviously with the pandemic that was not
possible so
we are waiting for that to come back to
us well we have a little surprise for
you we're sending you on a six night
seven day royal sweet stay to the
stunning boutique resort the mansion
bonnie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you so much drew thank you so
excited for both of you oh thank you so
much absolutely
[Applause]
i love you drew
i love you
our ross at um cbs 2 los angeles a big
special shout out and thank you for
helping us pull this off um so thank you
to our affiliate station we love you
we'll be right back thank you
[Music]
you